im Berliner Bezirk Pankow steht diese
eschenallee zwischen den Baumreihen
verläuft seit Jahrzehnten ein
unbefestigter Weg den die Menschen wie
selbstverständlich täglich nutzen doch
nun sollen 26 gesunde Bäume gefällt
werden damit ein Bürgersteig gebaut
werden kann
fünf Meter breit 250 Meter lang statt
grüner Bäume grau Betonfläche mitten in
der City viele Pankower können es nicht
glauben
absurd total darf ich nicht sagen was
ich sogar denke es ist einfach absurd
ich weiß nicht wie man auf die Idee
kommen kann völlig unnötigerweise weil
Platz ist hier genug
der ist so lange wie ich hier schon
wohne und da ist ja weg schon warum
wollen wir das alles wegreißen versteht
nicht
weil hier eine neue Schule gebaut wird
entscheidet die
Bezirksverordnetenversammlung der Alte
weg reicht nicht mehr ein richtiger
Bürgersteig muss her so weit so logisch
aber warum dafür tabula rasa machen mit
den Bäumen eine Bürgerinitiative will
die Eschen erhalten und einen schönen
Fußweg bauen Sie Fragen eine
fachplanerin die stellt fest man kann
die Bäume retten der Weg verläuft weiter
zwischen den Bäumen es wird einfach ein
wasserdurchlässiges pflasterband verlegt
fertig wir haben auch von dem Verein Pro
Kiez wir haben versucht mehrere
Vorschläge zu machen aber es findet
eigentlich keine Gesprächsbereitschaft
darüber statt wirklich zu sagen was ist
eigentlich das Problem was sind die
Alternativen im Bezirksamt Pankow bleibt
man hart die geplante Baumaßnahme sei
alternativlos man habe sich für eine
Variante entschieden bei der eine
sichere und barrierearme Nutzung bei
gleichzeitigem Erhalt zumindest der
Hälfte der Bäume ermöglicht wird
na super im Bezirksamt feiert man sich
also dafür dass man nur eine Baumreihe
abholst aus Protest gegen die
städtischen Pläne klebt die
Bürgerinitiative einen Hilferuf an die
Bäume und jetzt wird's völlig verrückt
denn dafür gibt es ein Knöllchen 50 Euro
mit ihrer Aktion hätten die Protestierer
mehrere geschützte Bäume beschädigt aha
bekleben verboten Fällen ist in Ordnung
wir finden es hochgradig absurd diese
Bäume sollen gefehlt werden und wir
sollen sie beschädigt haben durch
Tesafilm nicht nachvollziehbar muss man
wahrscheinlich ein Diplom von der
Baumschule haben und das zu verstehen
Ende des Jahres sollen die 26 Eschen
gefällt werden danach soll der neue
Bürgersteig entstehen kostenpunkt einer
satte Millionen Euro und übrigens das
Geld für die ganze Aktion kommt das
einem EU vor für nachhaltige Entwicklung
ah ja